um what's been going on man obviously
you you just put is the deluxe to your
uh project out the 35 song joint or is
that what's up
the 12 songs that was already okay with
this is dropping on it's like it in man
two for one type [__] like I mean I saw
you have there's 35 songs yeah 35 but
you basically get the list to the song
that's already out right now so I think
it's out that's like a triple [__] bro
but on the first one I had 32 so I had
to add three more only reason why I did
it like that because when I made the
hard copies you can only do 31 songs
well I think it's a certain amount of
minutes a certain amount of minutes
before you have to print two discs
exactly so I reached a minute so I'm
like all right [__] take a song off
type two uh I saw like last was it last
year you had or was it earlier this year
you had teased the possibility of a
deluxe of uh you and Draco [__] it's not
still coming no it's still coming it
really got pushed back because uh the
legendary tape had dropped
of course of course of course how is
it's got to be nice to have a guy like
Greedo home right yeah hell yeah we did
a cool video too that's all day yeah
that [__] was crazy it's a
little AI little effects and [__] have
you guys uh talked about doing a collab
project maybe you know what greeters the
work is easy we just get it in type [__]
I feel like he's got like that like high
output like yeah just like you and your
brother have like that's him and catch
you just like who I got it from just
that crazy out like output of just
like I remember like I was talking to TK
and I was like how many this was like
maybe last year I was like how many uh
Greedo songs he's like bro there's like
a thousand and it's over about that it
was a thousand before he went in
well because like he was recording like
he wasn't gonna get out for a very long
time so it's like you know you got to
keep keep up the output like and he was
dropping in videos I remember I went to
the studio one day at around the studio
that [__] did
15 songs the next day shot 15 mini music
videos so I'm like this [__] on some
[__] right now well every time I see you
you always have your videographer with
you is that something that you kind of
learned from being around those guys are
just because you're very on point with
your visuals I kind of like Incorporated
that like a year after what 2021
yeah it's like I've been trying to do it
but I couldn't find like the right
cameraman that was just like you got
yeah Cameron they got no what's up yeah
I mean [__] cameraman low key would be
[__] security guard too you gotta
make sure your cameraman ain't no [__]
you know so you can't be you know you're
gonna get robbed of this [__] camera
that should be happening
videographers
hip bruh
man I just had a homie go to the bay and
he lost all his [__] because he got
bipped
yeah that's [__] up it's crazy man
um so for you uh the Exotic pop the
water wasn't with him this is a you know
it was with them so okay so this is your
first soda though yeah this is my first
soda and there this is exotic pop that's
not the same company that's not rap
snacks I'm thinking of this coming out
of cops out here exotic pop Texas I
think they got raps next to it if I'm
mistaken they got rap snacks so it's out
of Pop's Base in Texas yeah so did you
go out there did you like how does this
work do you like try flavors do they mix
it up and like you're like I like that I
like this you know you just say I want
french vanilla pop man the good one you
let me see yeah that one type [__] you
know I mean them shits is everywhere now
I was just at a store and I saw Mac Dre
soda yeah they got actually like a peach
[__] vanilla type can that's like
this big
the image is fire but if you want to
post some mud in the [__] You
Gotta Buy like three or three folding
[__] all that sugar and then they
like ten dollars a piece so you're gonna
it's gonna have to cost too much so
um the last time uh you came on the show
you brought uh the otm guys no they're
not seeing too many more is this correct
no they just saw it you know you know is
it all is it positive is it negative
they went their separate ways or side
box you know so there's no it's no
animosity no they just didn't
continue the business that was already
on the floor you know